welcome to the program we start in
Ukraine where the russian-controlled
Japanese nuclear power plant has
suffered another power outage Ukraine's
state-owned power generating company
accused Russia of carrying out missile
strikes on Monday morning that cut off
the facility but Russia's defense
Ministry said Ukrainian shelling damaged
a high voltage line and caused the
blackout Let's cross over to Kiev where
we can join Natasha Butler correspondent
who's monitoring the events the blame
game has started and the power is
completely cut from this very important
nuclear facility
yes Russian administrators of the
zapariza nuclear plants say that the
plant has been cut from the power grid
it is now running they say on backup
diesel generators that information also
confirmed by Ukraine's nuclear agency
now what Ukraine's nuclear agency is
saying is that the power was cut because
of overnight Russian shelling in the
area missile and drone attacks and other
wave local authorities saying that a
number of buildings were damaged and at
least eight civilians were heard so
Ukrainian authorities are saying it is
because of these Russian attacks
and of course uh Natasha the other issue
that many will be worried about is sort
of the situation the dangerous situation
that this actually creates not just for
Ukraine and the immediate area but for
the much wider European continent
well indeed and uh cranes uh Atomic
officials are saying look uh these
backup diesel generators should have
enough fuel to keep the power going for
another 10 days but if the power is not
restored to this plant then they say and
these are their words that we could be
looking at a radiation accident with
consequences for the whole world well of
course that is the nightmare scenario
but it is worth just putting this in
context that this is the seventh time
that the power has been cut to the
sabarisia uh nuclear plants since uh
Russian forces occupied it in March last
year nevertheless it does really reveal
the ongoing difficulties for the workers
in this area particularly because of the
risks of these ongoing Russian attacks
for the update thanks very much Natasha
Butler there for us in Kiev